a lady whose husband we hung out with
this last weekend so uh we are in this
is a crazy story so we're in New York
okay
I took 34 of my guys my friends my
Executives and I said let's go to New
York we went to 11 Madison we had dinner
there we won't comment on that we had
dinner at 11 Madison and we had
afterwards we were trying to go to a
Yankees game the next day and uh it
rained out so we said listen guys I had
my kids with me my son was turning 10
years old Dylan oh my gosh happy
birthday Dylan he was 20 10 years old so
I got my 11 10 my seven-year-old
daughter with me we got to show him a
good time so we go to this place called
Chelsea Piers phenomenal place we go way
early 10 o'clock in the morning places
like wide open nobody said we get a
bunch of bowling lanes and we start
having conversations on who would you
like to have on the podcast Vinnie's
talking to me the door is behind me
Vinny's here Thomas here Sam is here Kim
is here and you're saying who would you
want to have and I I look at Pat and my
Drew Carey I'm wearing when he says
nobody's there I'm talking about they're
just setting up getting ready nobody's
there nobody is there and by the he just
randomly goes hey kids where do you want
to chill it was a last minute decision
because of the game Pat's back to the
door like he said and then I just hear
kind of talking hey Vinnie who do you
think will be a good interview for me to
interview and I go right up I didn't
even have to take care I go Putin
questions why I go because he's such a
polarizing individual I would love to
hear that type of conversation from him
because Pat would push him with
questions he's a very interesting guy I
go Pat who would you want and I'm not
joking okay this is this is 100 God's my
witness I'ma standing right next time is
right there Pat goes you know what I
wouldn't I wouldn't be interested in
interviewing Hillary but you know what
Bill Clinton I'm not even joking Carrie
I just see a white hair guy walk in
three seconds and it's Bill Clinton and
I go Pat remind me for my language I go
Pat Bill Clinton just walked into the
effing door the pack goes what the hell
is going very weird so Bill walks in
then what the little rocks and so tell
me the secret Santa Monica the Secret
Service guy walks up and I go up to him
I go Bill what are you doing and a
bowling alley goes do you know who my
wife is he goes anything I get away
no no
Hillary's in New Yorker I just had to go
anywhere
but he's by himself and I guess
there's like a a private party for some
kids which is great like 40 they were
having a private party and he walks in
and talks to an older couple which I
guess he knew and then mind you carry
Secret Service five or six he's just
walking around by the way if Kerry for
two hours he went no joke he probably
shook by the time it was done there was
a bunch of people there he probably
shook 150 people easy understands he
understood
politics he's so smooth so Hillary his
wife okay very different sweetheart
right Hillary Clinton most likable
warrants she warns of potential Russian
election interference in 2024 and she
said he'll do it again can you please
play that clip and let's get a reaction
yeah that's exactly what it is if you
can play the rabbi I thought you had the
clip prepared already you had it up
yeah no he had it up already isn't Rob
he's over there working his butt off wow
he's a good kid oh this is the issue
that's the one the ginger swindler oh
but Rob that's three minutes and five
seconds
one of these you pulled up earlier it
had the subtitles in Russian
they were it's when you walked out the
one I think it's the one on the bottom
the less than this one's 59 seconds okay
press it let's see what she says she's
pretty long with them
honestly your friend your friends should
be fair we've got one lucky guess who's
uh intervened in our election in the
past right it's not something as you
experience firsthand it's not something
we talk about a lot do you fear that
that is something that could be
happening for 2024. do you think we
should be talking about it more well I
think we should be talking about it more
because I don't think despite all of the
uh you know deniers uh there's any
doubtful deniers our election or that he
has interfered in many ways in uh the uh
Internal Affairs of other countries
funding political parties funding you
know political candidates uh buying off
uh you know government officials in
different places so that is his office
uh uh you know his his Opus operandi in
the sense that oh good one hey
hates us
has determined that he can do two things
do you guys do you guys understand what
like what's happening the gall of this
woman who was literally behind the
Russian collusion hoax about cheating is
over here warning us that Putin is gonna
do it this time like are you are you
kidding me like Is that real life
we're stuck in some sort of a loop right
now this whole country it's like they're
trying and the gas lighting has been so
off the charts and now they're going to
go completely with gas lighting like
this and it's just a repeat of what
they've been doing for the past eight
years oh there he is is that bill
look at them look at them look at that
shirt that shirt just says I'm going to
a bowling alley without my wife look at
that thing they would say fish shirt
with a blue blazer and a Ukraine flag no
he had a Ukraine flag on yeah he did
yeah he did and I didn't I didn't have
my Americans I would smoothness of ham
look at them that is working what he's
wearing just like an average Joe and
connecting with everybody we're not
answering the glaring question did you
ask him to be on the show uh no I did
not no but but the guy that was with him
the guy that was with him which was uh
very good to hear uh his secret service
guy was a fan of the show he watched a
podcast he says Mr David I watched a
podcast uh you you can approach uh
President Clinton and talk to him and we
had a very good conversation together my
wife
went to the same elementary school as he
did uh obviously not the same year
um
[Laughter]
your wife would be here's my wife you
know she's in the wheelchair
so anyways uh this is another joke of
another carry because uh but anyway so
uh yeah my wife and him went to the same
school so I said hey you know and he
said oh wow yes and then I also went to
your house and I noticed you were
recognized as the cutest baby you won an
award in 2010 and whatever the year was
yeah when he was two years old but in
the city we go to this Funeral House
okay and I go to this funeral home we're
there for a funeral my wife's dad passed
away so we're there for that reason Hope
Arkansas Hope Arkansas
so we go to this place and I say so tell
me uh how was uh Bill Clinton you know
what did you guys know about him in the
city and he says well what do you mean I
said is he the womanizer that people
claim he is he says of course he is I
said did you guys have a problem with
that he says you don't know who he's
married to yeah he says his wife he says
everybody here loves Bill he said well
let me tell you about his wife
he says one time Bill's uh Uncle dies
and he's up there giving a speech you
know there's a bunch of people there
says then Hillary sealed to the corner
she wanted to sit away from everybody
Bill's minklin with everybody I think
Bette Midler is there or something like
that
and he says afterwards they're going to
you know the plot to do the final you
know ceremony and she says we're there
with Secret Service security everybody
she says don't often expect me to go
there I'm going back home this is all
I'm gonna do here you go handle the rest
I gotta go home says she was the meanest
person we ever met Hillary Hillary
obviously it's surprising your story
never mind that smiles a lot right yeah
but you know it's you we don't know the
whole story there's a lot of different
stories behind it bill is a guy I would
love to have a long-form conversation
with I would also like to talk to her I
just don't think she'd ever do it never
no I think she would only do a long
conversation with someone where they
were parameters set and you are going to
ask about this and they're on the same
team and I think a lot of these people
in the media are part of the kind of
deep State
um una party they're they're in on it
all so if you would be willing to do
that I mean like I came on the show I
don't think that we had any parameters
no I don't I don't I usually tell people
I'll answer and anything may not be the
answer you want but I'll answer anything
and I don't believe that Hillary would
do that if you want to start asking her
about the 30 000 emails that are missing
um bleach bidding or phones you know if
you want to start asking her about all
more difficult questions money and where
the money went in Clinton my interest
was more hair product is what I wanted
to ask about I wanted to ask about hair
products or the real estate of friends
and employees yeah that just that just
can't handle leaving and not working
with them so they just they kill them
the question is believe me when she
starts talking about you and she did
start talking about me toward the end
they were worried with the Katie Hobbs
thing
um you know Bill Clinton was talking
about Hobbes and and Hillary started
talking about me they had Eric Holder
come in and campaign and Bill uh Obama
came in and campaigned which was the
funniest by the way he said he was going
after me saying oh she looks good on TV
and she's good on television and she can
speak well but Katie Hobbs chooses not
to look good she could look good but she
chooses is he actually trying to give me
an endorsement yeah yeah but when
Hillary Clinton starts talking about you
because of this history you do tense up
a little bit of course
oh boy let's check the brakes on the car
I'm in perfect health I'm not suicidal
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]